-Our first guest tonight
is a very funny actor, writer,
and director who you know from
"The Mindy Project"
and movies like "Suicide Squad"
and "Blockers."
He executive-produces and stars
in the animated series
"Chicago Party Aunt,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-Look at those paws.
What are you? A carpenter?
-No, carpentry is just a hobby.
I'm actually a firefighter.
-Oh! Oh, gosh.
Back...room...now.
[ Buzzer ]
-Diane, you just broke every
single rule in 12 seconds.
-Gideon, not now!
-This man is a hired actor.
You knew this!
Diane, he has been role-playing
all morning!
-You're an actor?
-I also played a coma victim
on "Chicago Med."
-Oh! A double gush!
Okay, this is entrapment.
I got witnesses.
-Please welcome back
to the show
our very good friend
Ike Barinholtz.
How are you, buddy?
-My man.
-Look at that. Representing,
Thank you so much.
-I'm representing,
but I got a purpose here.
So, I've had this shirt
for a while.
A few weeks ago, made a little
chicken piccata for the family.
And I got...
-You stained it.
-...stains here, here, and here.
-Okay, so, you want
another one?
And this time we'll try to
get it for you in your size.
-That's what I'm getting at.
Hey, listen -- Okay, okay.
I've put on a couple pounds
over quarantine.
Who hasn't?
-You basically admitted
you're out there making piccata.
-Well, I mean, I have to feed
my people, Seth.
My God.
Listen, X-L,
whatever color you guys want.
I see the dark blue.
They look real nice.
Adam Scott wore one.
I would love one of those.
At your leisure. No rush.
-Alright, thank you, buddy.
I am always genuinely so happy
to see you.
I wish you were here in person.
But I'm so very happy
about this project.
You are, of course,
a son of Chicago.
-Yes!
-And this is a loving --
a loving portrait of
Chicago people, this cartoon.
-Chicago has given me
so many gifts,
and I thought it was time
to give something back
to the city of broad shoulders.
-Yeah.
-And so, we -- you know,
our friend Chris Witaske,
who you know,
started this Twitter feed
many years ago
called "Chicago Party Aunt,"
and it was funny and
kind of goofy and stuff.
And we would interact with it.
And then, one day, our friend
Richie Schwartz said,
"Hey, I think this could be
a funny animated show."
And Netflix bought it,
and now this insanely stupid
inside joke
between me and a few friends
is in like 400 countries.
[ Laughter ]
It's crazy.
-Would you admit that --
So, you were --
You were born in the '80s
in Chicago.
-The late '70s, but thank you.
-But so you were old enough
to appreciate the '86 bears,
and then you lived through
the Jordan Bulls.
And I have always felt,
even though I have
a great many friends
who that is true of,
that you are some of the most
insufferable people on Earth.
-Well, I mean, that comes --
That's a lot, coming from
a Red Sox and a Steelers fan.
-Yeah, that's true.
-But, yeah -- no, Chicago fans,
we are very entitled.
We still consider the Bears
an elite football team,
even though the last time
we won a Super Bowl,
"Miami Vice" was
the number-one show on TV.
[ Laughter ]
But, you know, we're babies.
We're definitely babies
with our sports.
But we're sweet babies.
-How has Netflix been?
You've worked with
a great many studios
over your illustrious career.
This is your first time
with Netflix.
How have they been so far?
-I'm in the algorithm.
I'm in there now.
I'm running stuff, you know --
-They've given you access
to the algorithm?
-I now am the one who kind of --
behind the scenes,
me and Ted Sarandos
are kind of moving stuff around.
It's fun. It's really cool.
It's so cool that it's
in so many different countries.
The good thing
about "Chicago Party Aunt,"
it's probably the same name
in every other country.
You know, like, other countries
the show is called, like,
"Aunt Lois in Latvia."
We called it
"Chicago Party Aunt,"
so we just cut out
the middle man,
so it's great that
all these different countries
are gonna see the insanely silly
jokes we put up.
-You, of course, had
your fair share of parties
in Chicago over the years.
And you had a pretty --
For a young man who wanted
to be involved in comedy,
you got some pretty-early
interactions with some legends.
-Yeah, well, you know,
we both went through
the Chicago improv scene
in the mid- to late '90s.
And it was super exciting
just because you would,
you know, get to watch, like,
Tina and Rachel Dratch
and Kevin Dorff onstage.
But you would also get, like,
the old legends
that would come back.
And I got to meet Chris Farley
one time -- super cool.
Like, I walked into
the e.t.c. Theater --
like, the other theater --
and it was dark.
And he was in there by himself,
maybe smoking a joint.
I don't know. I can't remember.
But I got to hang out with him.
And I remember thinking like,
"I'm -- This is it.
This is the pinnacle
of my career.
I got to meet Chris Farley."
And like four months later,
we were at the Last Act,
the bar across the street,
and he walked in and saw me
and goes, "Do you know
where my brother is?!"
And I was like, "Oh, yeah,
he's at this party."
And I said to my friend
from high school,
"Do you mind if we drive
Chris Farley to this party?"
And we were driving
and he goes,
"I got to pee, I got to pee!"
And we pulled out, like,
underneath the "L" tracks,
and I was like,
"I got pee, too."
And as we're peeing,
Chris is like,
"Do you want to play Swords?"
You know,
the classic game Swords.
You're with your young friends
and you're both peeing,
and you kind of...
cross the streams.
-Yeah, it's a fun game.
-I'm like, "Yeah, sure!"
It's a very fun game.
I hadn't played it
since I was 7 or 8,
but it's Chris Farley.
So we kind of played Swords
for a second.
Then, he just turns
and just pees all up my leg
and just started, like,
cackling hilariously.
And, uh, yeah,
still have the jeans.
Haven't washed them.
Still wear them.
[ Laughter ]
They stink.
But it's a nice memory.
-It is a nice memory.
I have a lot more
to ask you about.
We'll be right back
with more from Ike Barinholtz.